In Brazil, the top federal prosecutor charges President Michel Temer...
...with taking multimillion-dollar bribes in a stinging blow to Temer...
...and the political stability of Latin America's largest country.
In the US, US ambassador to the United Nations Nikki Haley...
...said the Trump administration issued a warning to Syria...
...over a possible chemical weapons attack...
...after seeing preparations similar to activities before the April attack.
In Scotland, First Minister Nicola Sturgeon shelves the country's plans...
...to hold a second independence referendum...
...until after the terms of Britain's exit from the European Union are clear.
In France, the French parliament elects Francois de Rugy as speaker.
And finally, a local NGO in the city of Yei, is working with girls...
...to help promote peace and an end to early marriages in South Sudan.